[Musik]
amerikanische system sagt dem bauch ein
licht im kopf und robson das nennt man
zehn jahre jünger ok also mein name ist
in ihr die expert ich habe meinen namen
schon vier mal geändert weil ich drei
mal verheiratet war
ich bin jetzt bald 94 und ich bin in
einem programm vom drk dass man 120
werden kann
ich habe auch immer lieb habe auch mit
90 liebt man sex hat man liebesaffären
es hört nie auf
man stirbt aus langeweile und einsamkeit
um man stirbt wenn man sterben will
botschaft an alle leute
[Musik]
haben sie noch fragen ich habe noch eine
klar was ist in talente suchen sie hier
wenn talente zu überleben
sie hat den holocaust überlebt hollywood
überlebt drei ehemänner und mehrere
liebhaber die nächsten 30 jahre will die
94 jährige auch noch überleben warum sie
deshalb an einer talentshow teilnehmt
davon handelt dieser film ich besuche
ihn ginsberg in ihrem zürcher zu hause
davon hat sie einige überall auf der
welt gerade aus new york angereist lädt
sie spontan ein
das du hat sie mir bereits im ersten
male angeboten
darf ich das mal ort
denn dank mandler michael das ist ins
persönliche assistenz so wollte die
wohnung
die wohnung ist die küche ich bin fan
gourmet koch und das sieht man ja an den
vielen gewürzen
ich brauche natürlich gesund ist alles
was feines sollte ein ganzes video aus
amerika mitgebracht da kostet das kilo
acht fragen und tier kostet was 50 16
lassen sie mir immer vor wie so ein
naturmensch bin so was wollt ihr noch
wir sind glaube das ist vielleicht das
will ich will ich zeigen weil ich darauf
stolz bin ich bin natürlich die heute
als rap sänger auf die bühne war noch
nie auf einer bühne eben wieder zebra er
sagt man muss wenn man jung bleiben will
muss man jeden tag etwas machen was man
noch nie gemacht hat dies zeigt euch was
macht so verschränkt die hände schon
werde ich geprüft alters test und früh
übt sich wer ewig jung bleiben will aber
alle finger und sehr gute reaktion beide
hirnhälften funktionieren fantast immer
noch gut welche alte geht zum ersten mal
auf die bühne
tanz trug ich will jung kleben und ich
bin innerlich jung und jetzt kommt eben
die serie diese job ich bin will bis 120
läden zu hause ich mache natürlich die
sonnenanbeter
wie wird man 120 geht es nach engels
anti aging guru job dann sieht das in
etwa so aus
zusätzliche gebote der langlebigkeit
lehre den eigenen körperzellen gut
zureden ausleben der sexualität täglich
aus dem gefängnis der gewohnheiten
ausbrechen und sowohl negative gedanken
aus auch negative menschen schnell
hinter sich lassen so das machst du
täglich zehn jahre in irgendeiner form
immer warum möchtest du so alt werden
ich habe noch sehr viele projekte nicht
fertig und ich möchte noch nicht ich
wollte immer so lang leben bist da habe
die bessere sabbel ist sie sehr
weltraumsonde de bis sie beim mars
wortmann ist längst dort also jetzt will
ich länger leben
eine kleine kostprobe
zusammen mit den ebenfalls aus new york
angereist und musikern lucia caruso und
pedro da silva wird er an der talentshow
mit diesem stück auftreten
hierzu den songtext hat er vor zehn
jahren selber geschrieben allerdings zur
melodie eines walzers die idee daraus
eine rocknummer zu machen ist erst im
vorfeld der talentshow entstanden
jetzt beginnt alles neu
[Musik]
ja das ist zieht ihr verhalten nicht
klar
wir sind schon zehn jahre zu sammeln was
haben ich habe sie als meine
enkeltochter angenommen wie ich meine
eigene ente tochter verloren habe und
sie ist jetzt so wie meine ältere
tochter
wieso hat sind die ränke das erzähle ich
ihnen diesmal nicht in den top gesetzten
professor schimpf bekommen darauf zurück
zunächst aber geht es im casting weiter
müssen wie oft will die den soundtrack
das glaube ich
bevor es am singen geht soll mit hilfe
ihres assistenten michi die anmelde
formulare ausfüllen der sehen sie da
könnte keine künstlername ist nur für
mich kompliziert familienstand segen
nein verweht wird seine familie mit dem
song geben sind ja alle eine tauchte
eine tochter einer merkel seine drei
besten freunde vor und nachname das ist
überhaupt alles was du nicht
das ist richtig viele sind verstorben
allein dies ist es wohl nicht in ines
erlebnis strahlen und flüchtigen leben
scheint wenig platz für wahre
verbindlichkeit
trotz alledem so erzählt mir zu hause
habe sie nie allein sondern zeitlebens
in wechselnden liebesbeziehungen geliebt
wenn mein letzter liebhaber hat mich und
meine große lebenswert und ich habe
gesagt dass trotz welchen erwähnen hatte
sie verloren nicht wirklich wir sind
immer noch irgendwie in kontakt aber
irgendwie es ist auch nicht gegangen als
40 jahre jünger und ein deutscher und es
gab viele werde ich gerne genannt und
soll das hatte mir drin geschäft weil
ich mich an ihn anklamer sowie die koala
als selber am baum sind sie ein
clownerie
ich bin eine klamme ring ja ich zeige
euch die fotos aus aus aus rache ist
ebenso schön dahin sind noch unklar
der kam zu mir nach amerika aha das ist
mein haus in amerika ich war dreimal
verheiratet der erste war ein
österreicher der mit mir schweizer wurde
das weite weil israel luxushotel im
luxushotel dann hotel und der dritte war
von ecuador und alle drei waren wiener
juden
das haben sie alle gemeinsam und und sie
erklärt ist die ob ich immer da solange
nicht glücklich war bin ich geblieben
und wenn es mir nicht billig wie immer
bin ich weggegangen ist das erste mal
dass mit dem wort gesagt okay ich kann
das nicht wie sehr wird mit sowas
passiert einem nicht wie das geht weiß
nicht mal welche seite die richtige ist
verständlich
ich möchte mir lieder vorspielen und
jetzt schlager gehört komponiert von
ihrem ersten mann auto kollmann
beschrieb die texte jetzt ginge und otto
haben es bis nach hollywood geschafft
[Musik]
das ist nat king cole der berühmte nat
king cole für den haben wir geschrieben
ja protokoll man ja ja ja und dann für
unser großes aber den markt in die
martin däne martin welches stück mit
drei gehen was übersetzt war von quitte
pas rhema denn was machst du in paris
modellen in deutsch und dann ein
englisch 3f fonds she's not gegen den
martin sechs wochen auf der heeper
berühmt geworden
und dann haben wir auch bedeckt mit
berühmt geworden und reicht nicht weil
die agenten stellen alles dinge und ihr
mann otto waren in den 50er jahren ein
erfolgreiches duo die bühne aber gehörte
anderen jetzt mit 94 will inge selber
ins rampenlicht ihr ticket zum erfolg
ist nicht ihr gesang auch nicht ihre
performance es ist ihr hohes alter
ich habe das gefühl dass thun gewissen
autos bonus hast also jetzt auf die show
bezogen
erst gar nicht ran gekommen das ist ja
meine attraktion neben für sich so alt
bin und trotzdem noch etwas macht und
das ist vielleicht auch eine botschaft
an die anderen alten dass sie sich die
glauben wir jetzt wenig angeht muss ich
jetzt brauche ich da machen sie alle den
gleichen fehler dann gehen sie aus
großen wohnungen in der 1
im oder zwei zimmer in einer
alterssiedlung und dann können sie dort
nicht existiert
ines motto hingegen vormarsch statt
rückzug dran an neue projekte wie dieses
die grössten schweizer talente
[Musik]
solange man noch alles da
okay okay
[Musik]
am 1
die band proben
[Musik]
über geld
nur waren
ist das scheinwerferlicht auf sie
gerichtet blüht dinge auf die teilnahme
an dieser show des schweizer fernsehens
ist wie ein jungbrunnen
neu
[Musik]
okay okay
meine jahre dinge mag den großen
auftritt im mittelpunkt stehen das spürt
man
deshalb mache ich sehr gerne part ist
wenn ich fertig bin ich bewusst ist und
alle müssen wir die aufmerksamkeit
schenken
das hat sie gern oder sehr gern wieso so
binnen am ganzen leib ich so bin ich und
so bleibe ich an dir ganz wenig
aufmerksamkeit kauf an zieht wenig
aufmerksamkeit kopf immer aufmerksamkeit
bin sehr verwöhnt vom leben und auch
mitgeprüft beides ehemaliges
flüchtlingslager adliswil bei zürich
hierhin flut die junge wiener jüdin inge
vor der nazi herrschaft ein teil ihrer
familie wurde während des holocaust
umgebracht
gemeinsam mit dem historiker christian
sieber kehren wir am eines ehemaligen
zufluchtsort zurück ich hatte vor einer
woche das bild weiter vergrößere
wie das in la cruz hat damals darf ich
das kunststoff dass ich ihm es sei ja
also da
die mittlere stock ja und das ist im
dachstock werden die wirte neue
gerichtet hat mit kind und da hat es
auch noch einige aufnahmen aus der zeit
mit der familie
alle haben alpträume gehabt die ganze
nacht hat man werde man schreien und
gehört und ich habe noch bis vielleicht
vor zehn 15 jahre jede nacht alpträume
gehabt das bleibt ich glaube jetzt habe
ich keine mehr ist nicht mehr nachts
immer wieder weggelaufen und über die
grenze und angst gehabt dass das bleibt
dem blut fotos von ihnen aus dieser zeit
gibt es keine einziges dokument der
offizielle flüchtlings ausweis die 22
jährige inge es zusammen mit ihrer
mutter ihrem kleinen bruder und ihrem
damaligen verlobten auto in die schweiz
geflohen
da sieht man dass das war das gleiche
richtung
das war ich ja sagen wir jetzt beim
verlobte für die energie ins berg oder
arbeitslager
ja ich habe 300 paar socken jeden tag
gewaschen vernahm also sie wann die
maschine aber ich hab's ja wohl in
luzern fällt mir ist alles sei
ich verstand eigentlich noch dass sie so
wohlwollend von dieser zeit regen hat
uns das leben gerettet
die zeit aus flüchtlingen hat ihn
geprägt nicht bloß überleben nein sie
will leben erleben jeden tag aufs neue
dabei
[Musik]
das wird wird das foto gemacht als er
das kapital bereit
ja es gut die dinge ist sich bewusst für
viele ist sie mit ihrer nummer hier bloß
die skurrile alte belächelt selbst von
ihren verwandten und ich glaube das darf
sie auch nicht erwähnt
und die da wird gesagt wenn du dich
darauf gewöhnlich lässt sich erste doch
dass du von dir gewissen
gesellschaftskreisen ausgeschlossen ist
hab ich gesagt das ist gut so es prima
dann ging er zurück weil ich hier weil
ich ein totem s11 diese beifall betritt
us 11 das weiß ich bin wenig einfach
singen und zwar nicht realistisch im
sinne vorm mikrofon so dass sich die
täter über die emotionen sind okay mal
sehen erstaunlich dass trotz
schicksalsschlägen so viel lebenslust
und 0 verbitterung geblieben sind
[Applaus]
in meine eigenen und daher sind sie doch
ist diese gute laune nicht zuweilen auch
kalkül indikator ist das eine maske die
fröhlichen alltag eines gut so wenn man
alt ist hat man das relativ hat er das
recht das zu sein was man selber ist
muss nicht mehr
[Gelächter]
kompromisslos man selber sein etwas hin
und wieder geht das wohl nur auf kosten
anderer zurück bei ihm zu hause gehen
wir zwei stockwerke tiefer
hier hat sie noch eine wohnung und jetzt
habe ich die wohnung meiner tochter
überlassen
ja ja und der bc ist es meistens in
amerika und das ist neben den schläger
weg
und ja und die fotos sollten da drinnen
sein
ein inniges familienleben scheint es
nicht zu geben
wir müssen sie denn aus fertig das ist
meine tochter mit erklären will wie will
die kurze zeit die werden das ist auf
meinem dach in new york das größte
tochter jetzt in amerika und wie ist das
verhältnis sehr gut wenn wir 3000 mal 19
uhr dann da ist ungerecht und das ist
die das ist die michelle wie sie klein
war und das ist die wahre und wie sie
klein war
michelle ist die enkelin die hast du
gesagt hast du verloren
die habe ich verlor wieso durch die wird
die amerikanische total korrupt
gerichtswesen eine lange geschichte kurz
zusammengefasst
dinges tochter marion lag aufgrund eines
autounfalls längere zeit im koma und
fand danach nur langsam ins leben zurück
enkeltochter michelle wurde vom gericht
dem vater zugesprochen
kontakt mit mir ich glaube meine tochter
sie ihr braucht er beschließt das für
sie als großmutter er fürchterlich ich
habe bei diesen riesen vakuum ich habe
keine familie geldes dass man sagt es
des tors pflaster wenn man alte zehnte
enkelkinder und das habe ich nicht
deshalb stürzte ich mich sollen die sehr
in die arbeit damit ich mit anderen mit
sache geht ein können wir mit euch gern
mit jungen leuten kontakt kontakt ab und
wenn nicht er sechs enkelkinder hat wird
wahrscheinlich auch aber es kein ersatz
oder für die liebe frau kann ist mein
blut ist blut
was im eigentlichen leben fehlt bekommt
sie hier
die teilnahme an der show bringt die
nötige portion bestätigung und
anerkennung
martinstag
ja wenn die maus der auftritt bei die
grössten schweizer talente ist für inge
anteil ihres überlebens projekt sie will
nicht die jury nicht das publikum nein
sie will vor allem sich selber
unterhalten wie dieses spezielle talent
ankommt wird sich nächsten samstag
zeigen
[Musik]
mehr
wetzlar
[Musik]
alles
dreimal
ja